judiciary committee will come to order a
quorum being present having agreed
yesterday to the amendment and the
nature of a substitute of articles of
impeachment against President Donald J
Trump the pending business is reporting
the resolution favorably to the house
reporting quorum being present the
question is now on the motion to report
the resolution h.res 755 as amended
favorably to the house pursuant to
Clause 5 of house rule 16 because the
resolution contains two distinct
propositions we will divide the question
between the two articles the question
now is on article 1 of the resolution
impeaching President Donald J Trump for
abusing his powers the clerk will call
the roll
mr. Nadler aye mr. Nadler votes
I miss Lofgren hi miss Lofgren votes aye
miss Jackson Lee I miss Jackson Lee
votes aye mr. Cohen ah mr. Cohen votes
aye mr. Johnson of Georgia
aye mr. Johnson of Georgia votes aye mr.
Deutsch aye
mr. Deutsch avoids I miss bass I miss
bass votes aye mr. Richmond yes mr.
Richmond votes yes mr. Jeffries aye
mr. Jeffries votes aye mr. Cicilline aye
mr. Cicilline votes aye mr. suave Oh aye
mr. suave ah votes aye mr. Liu mr.
Raskin hi mr. Raskin votes aye miss
jayapal I miss Jaya Paul votes I miss
Demmings I miss Demmings votes aye mr.
Korea
yes mr. Korea votes yes miss Scanlon
I miss Scanlon votes I miss Garcia I
miss Garcia votes aye mr. [ __ ] aye
mr. new goose votes I miss Macbeth I
miss Macbeth votes aye mr. Stanton aye
mr. Stanton votes I miss Dean I miss
Dean votes I misma carcel Powell I miss
McCardle Powell
it's I miss Escobar I miss Escobar's
boots I mr. Collins mr. Collins votes no
mr. Sensenbrenner mr. sensenbrenner
votes no mr. Chabot no mr. Chabot votes
no mr. Gohmert my vote is no mr. Gohmert
votes no mr. Jordan no mr. Jordan votes
no mr. buck no mr. buck votes no mr.
Radcliffe mr. Radcliffe votes no mr.
Robie mr. Robie votes no mr. gates no
mr. gates votes no mr. Johnson of
Louisiana no mr. Johnson of Louisiana
votes no mr. Biggs no mr. baek's votes
no mr. McLintock
no mr. McLintock votes no mr. schoo no
miss let's go votes no mr. Russian
thought mr. Rosenthal our votes no mr.
Klein no mr. Klein votes no mr.
Armstrong no mr. Armstrong votes no mr.
Stu be mr. Snoopy votes no does every
member voted who wishes to vote mr.
chairman hat may I ask how I'm recorded
I was the gentleman recorded mr. gohmert
you recorded us now yeah I want to make
sure clerk will report
mr. chairman there are 23 eyes and 17
nose the article is agreed to
the question now is an article 2 of the
resolution impeaching President Donald J
Trump for obstructing Congress the clerk
will call the roll
mr. Nadler aye
mr. Nadler votes aye miss Lofgren I miss
Lofgren votes aye miss Jackson Lee oh I
miss Jackson Lee votes aye
mr. Cohen ah mr. Cohen votes aye mr.
Johnson of Georgia
aye mr. Johnson of Georgia votes aye mr.
Deutsch hi mr. Deutsch votes I miss pass
I miss
votes aye mr. Richmond yes mr. Richmond
votes yes mr. Jeffries
aye mr. Jeffries votes aye mr. Cicilline
aye
mr. Cicilline votes aye mr. suave Oh aye
mr. suave ah votes aye mr. Lew mr.
Raskin
hi mr. Raskin votes I miss Jaya Paul
I miss Jaya Paul votes I miss Demings I
miss Demings votes aye
mr. Correa yes mr. Correa votes yes miss
Scanlon
I miss Scanlon boots I miss Garcia I
miss Garcia votes aye mr. [ __ ] aye
mr. new goose boats I miss Macbeth I
miss Macbeth votes aye mr. Stanton aye
mr. Stanton but I miss Dean I miss Dean
votes aye mr. Carsen Powell I miss Ben
cárcel Powell votes I missed Escobar I
miss Escobar's votes aye
mr. Collins no mr. Collins votes no mr.
Sensenbrenner mr. sensenbrenner votes no
mr. Chabot mr. Chabot votes no mr.
Gohmert no mr. gohmert votes no mr.
Jordan mr. Jordan votes no mr. buck mr.
buck votes no mr. Radcliffe mr.
Radcliffe votes no mr. Robie mr. Robie
votes no mr. gates no mr. gates votes no
mr. Johnson of Louisiana no mr. Johnson
of Louisiana votes no mr. baek's no mr.
baek's votes no mr. McLintock
no mr. McLintock votes no mr. SEO no
miss let's go votes no mr. Rushworth are
no mr. Rosenthal our votes no mr. Klein
no mr. Klein votes no mr. Armstrong Oh
mr. Armstrong votes no mr. Stu be mr.
steuby votes no every man
the committee who wishes to vote voted
clerk will report
mr. chairman there are 23 eyes and 17
nose the article is agreed to
the resolution as amended is ordered
reported favorably to the house members
will have two days to submit views the
resolution will be reported as a single
amendment in the nature of a substitute
without objection step is authorized to
make technical and conforming changes
that objection as to mr. chairman
pursuing my purpose does the gentleman
seek recognition return to clause 2l
overall 11 I give notice of intent to
file dissenting these notice is heard
without objection the committee is
adjourned